[Música]
não não tô querendo dizer
ai ai
hoje é meu aniversário de 23 anos vem um
presente de aniversário que eu quero de
você é que você clique em gostei agora
explicar eu gostei eu sei que apenas
relata pelo computador pelo tablet
'gostei aqui em baixo e você está
andando presente
tá bom hoje é aniversário de hoje eu
faço 23 anos acabei de acordar então
exatamente 13 horas e 14 minutos ou na
tarde e essa é a diferença de quando
você completa 23 anos quando você
completa 12 anos já chega ao aniversário
de 12 anos está tão ansioso para fazer
12 anos e acorda de madrugada já tenho
do vinho sem dormir de novo que não tem
para quem encontrar graça de fazer 12
anos é contar pra todo mundo já tem 12
anos eu cortei 12 anos não podia ver um
grupo mm menor que o contato ainda tem
muitos anos 78 12 eu via minha mãe
conversando com alguém falar o feed
fulano já tem 10 anos e dizia que não é
o meu caso né porque o youtube e essa
diferença é a animação do aniversário de
12 anos se acorda assim meu deus do céu
como eu estou másculo é [ __ ] até 12
anos
o aniversário de 23 anos recorda assim o
cantor e foi o que aconteceu
eu estou sem saber onde é que eu estou
que qualquer um não vou tomar a minha
vinha sem ninguém só sempre sozinha
agora fiquei no deserto hoje amiga eu me
acorda e chocado e só um matagal a
marido com nem deixaram mais ferro e não
a idade que você quer falar com o povo
que tem pessoal pergunta quanto tempo
você não sabe o que é falta de educação
perguntar quantos anos tem uma mulher
aniversário de 23 anos ela é mapear todo
18 18 14 e 18 anos e escutar a mesma
coisa o dia todinho ai ai e já pode ser
presa
um homem se for sua vontade ser preso ou
se tivesse ao ver que o sonho da pessoa
fosse preto é isso que eu quero para
minha vida quando eu completar 18 anos
lutou muito na minha mãe uma paulada na
cabeça da minha avó já pode bpm pb
coloca o cara vai fazer com 18 anos já
fazia com 15
já é legal se mexe com 15 anos também o
amor de amigo a garrafa de pinto
escondido no meio do mato é legal de
marcos tiveram a cor que me deixa
desconfortável de mais nada parabéns a
única pessoa da confortável quem está
cantando a professora aniversaria nunca
sabe como é que se comporta na hora do
parabéns a todo mundo para bem está você
nessa data então aniversariando não sabe
se bate papo mãos a bicicleta jogo se o
povo não é bobo se a favela área bem
está você
parabéns sempre uma pessoa pode tomar
uma fatia de café com red bull com
cocaína na avenida a tortura está
acabando já está preparado para soprar
vela roubar que cheiram cocaína ontem
será com quem será só serve pra quem é
apaixonado sabe quem tem aquela pessoa
alma gêmea de todo mundo conhece é na
hora h e dependência bruna vai querendo
falar com ele com jundiá bruno é todo
mundo é esse seu amor todo mundo a festa
já sai quando chega na hora de dizer o
nome da pessoa chega fala todo mundo
alto juquinha bruna vai que a explosão
de amor que a bruna eu sorrio
aniversário de sorriso e corta orgulho
primeiro pedaço vai parar aí dá para a
mãe a bruna fica puto e assim como é
essa rivalidade entre a mulher ea sogra
agora encara namorado shane esquema com
quem será o sabe que o cara namorado
cheio de escape na hora do com quem será
temos que ficar calados sozinho
ai ai na hora se a roupa aypb vai
depender ainda dependesse adjunto na
mulher
vou julho na live lívia do ju bruna vai
querer
e abro nem tá no aniversário de talaia
julho já percebi que quanto mais um
aniversário menor é o bolo 8 comemora
hoje com a saírem agora estranho mesmo
pra mim é quem faz aniversário de
cachorro eu não consigo galera faz um
bolo de ração de cachorro primeiro
cachorro nem goste de ração cachorro
come porque é o que tem é como se no dia
do aniversário dessa bolha de sopa sopa
não janta não tem amigo do adversário o
cachorro é só ele que vocês
e quando tem amigo é o de cachorro que
quer seus amigos que tem um cachorro nem
amigo do seu cachorro ninguém canta com
quem será que vou gostar com quem será
vão cantar com a idéia é perder a idéia
é perder
a almofada vai querer geralmente a do
cachorro
ciça seia e termino parabéns só que como
bola o cachorro eu queria que o cachorro
nessa hora pudesse falar pelo cortar o
bolo falar assim o primeiro pedaço vai
para minha do ro na agora você vai comer
vai com essa merda que você fez e vai
comer só isso
feliz aniversário e pra mim o meu
presente de aniversário se sabe é
clicado gostei aí tá não se esquece de
se inscrever no canal já tem muita gente
que me assiste e que não inscrita no meu
canal sabiá recebeu o vídeo então o que
você faz você vai clicar aqui e
inscrever-se aqui embaixo eu quero que
você comente aqui embaixo a fama mais
estranho que já aconteceu com você no
seu aniversário